Astro is an all-in-one web framework for
building fast content-focused websites
like landing pages blogs technical
documentation and more in this course
James Q Quick will teach you about this
increasingly popular framework James is
a popular instructor and keynote
conference speaker he's the perfect
person to teach you about Astro let's
learn all about Astro one of the most
exciting and up-and-coming JavaScript
Frameworks my name is James he quick and
I absolutely love Astro so in this crash
course we're going to cover some of the
Core Concepts of Astro along the way
we'll talk about file based routing
creating and managing markdown and MDX
contact with content Collections and
typescript we'll talk about Dynamic
routes and we'll even at the end of this
video get into deploying this to netlify
and versel we'll also talk about the
server-side capabilities of Astro going
from a statically generated site to a
server-side rendered site and show you
how you can add server endpoints to your
Astro application as well lastly we'll
talk about a few neat features of Astro
along the way like view transitions
which allows you to add beautiful
transitions between your pages and your
Astro application with just one line of
code now if you enjoy what we cover in
this crash course and you want to learn
more you can check out my full course at
astrocourse.dev to learn all the ins and
outs of Astro 3.0 that said let's go
ahead and get started let's start on the
Astro documentation page where we can
see the getting started instructions for
creating a brand new project with Astro
version 3 which is the most recent
version of Astro now on this
documentation page they kind of give you
an overview some of the things that
we've talked about some key features Etc
and then if you scroll down they'll give
you a couple of ways to get started with
Astro one cool way to do that is with
the astro.new website and what this is
is a collection of different Astro
projects that you can open up that have
already been created and kind of get
started working with them right inside
of Stack Blitz now in this case we're
going to create our own project from
scratch so we're going to do this inside
of our own vs code window and terminal
to be able to create the project and
then go and work and build out the
tutorial or the blog that we're going to
build now one thing I do want to show
and we'll kind of reference this
throughout this crash course is the
ability to search for anything that we
might want in this course on the Azure
documentation page so once you get to
the Astro docs you can come up to the
top left and you can click to open the
search window and you can search for a
server or anything server side rendering
for example and then click on one of
these and go straight to those pages the
other thing I want to show you that's
pretty neat is on this page you can hold
command K on Mac or control K on Windows
to be able to pull that up as well so
you don't have to go and click that
yourself you can just open that with the
shortcut window
that said what we're going to do is copy
this command to be able to create a
brand new Azure project and then run
this in our terminal so that we can get
started
so I'm going to scroll over to my vs
code window and this is an open mtvs
code window and I'm going to first
switch over to the directory that I want
to create the project so I'm going to
switch into code and then my demos
directory and then from here I'm going
to paste in that command from the Azure
docs to create the new project so once I
press enter this will ask me a few
different things first of all are we
okay installing the package that's
needed to generate our project and this
is actually a good error to have here so
with the latest version of Astro you're
required to have a version 18 or higher
of node.js to be able to run the
installer so I wanted to leave this in
as a reminder that you'll need to be
working with a version 18 or higher now
for me personally I use NVM to manage my
different versions of node to handle
this this is the easiest way that I
found to handle working with different
versions of node so I can use my NVM
command and then NVM use and then type
18 and this will let me use a version of
node that is a 18. now I can also use
NVM to install a version of node like 20
for example and that will go and install
a different version of node that I could
use at any time but in this case since
I'm now using version 18 I can scroll
back through my commands and run that
same create command inside of my
terminal now you see we get the really
awesome animated experience where Astro
is going to walk us through creating
this new project
so in this case we need to give it a
folder that we're going to create the
project in I'm going to call this FCC
Astro crash course so you'll just do dot
slash and then whatever the folder is of
whatever the name is of the folder that
you wanted to create in
this case we're going to start with
sample files you could also choose a
Blog template where they'll have a lot
of the stuff done that we will be
building from scratch you could also
additionally choose an empty project to
just start completely from scratch in
this case we'll accept the sample files
and what it's doing now is it's going to
start to copy over the sample files
which is done and then it's going to ask
whether or not we want it to install the
dependencies and we can press enter on
yes and let it go and run and install
all of these dependencies
so we'll let that run for a second and
come back when it's finished all right
so those dependencies have been
installed and the next question is do we
plan to write typescript which in this
case we do so we'll click yes and then
we'll choose the strict or recommended
version of how strict with typescript we
should be lastly the question is do we
want this to initialize a new git
repository in this case we'll say yes
because we're going to use this
repository to deploy this later on to
netlify and versel
so we'll click yes here
and then we get our out animation from
Houston which is the Astro mascot we'll
come back to Houston in a little bit and
the next thing I want to do is open this
project inside of vs code so I can use
the command code R which means to reuse
the window that I'm currently in and
then I'm going to choose my SEC Astro
crash course window
notice it pops up here with this
intellisense if you're curious where
this little window is coming from this
is coming from an extension called fig
dot IO which is really great to kind of
supercharge your powers inside of your
terminal
so I'm going to press enter and then
we'll open this up inside of that same
window in vs code and now I'm going to
go to the bottom and open my terminal
again and inside of here I'm going to
run npm run Dev and this should now
start our Astro project and it will run
it at Port
4321 they chose this port because it is
kind of like four three two one blast
off which is kind of neat so I'm going
to open a new tab in my browser and open
up my browser to localhost 4321 and you
see this is the starter application that
we get with Astro where we have a
welcome to Astro we have a little code
challenge of how to make an update to
this which is right here then we have
links to documentation integration
themes Community Etc so we have our
beginner Astro application created let's
go and walk through the code and talk a
little bit about what all is there
so first off we have our public
directory this is where we would store
any public assets like images or other
things that we want to be publicly
available from our site now these are
going to be directly available after the
end of the URL so what this means is
since we have
favicon.svg we could come to the end of
our URL and type in
favacon.svg and now that'll take us to
that file which is not going to show a
whole lot because it's an SVG and we're
not going to have good visibility here
but we do have the access to be able to
access that directly so anything that
you put inside of the public directory
will just be shipped with your built
version of your site and included and
would be available after the slash in
your url after that we have our source
directory this is where all of our code
is really going to live and what Astro
really depends on is this page based
routing where we have different files
under the Pages directory are going to
represent as you might have guessed it
different pages in your application
so let's just open the
index.astro file and take a look the
first thing we'll notice is that it is a
DOT ASTRO File it's not a DOT JS it's
not a DOT TS this is dot Astro and this
obviously is going to signify to the
developer to yourself and to your editor
we'll talk about this in a minute that
this is an astro component now Astro
components are made up of two different
sections there is the kind of JavaScript
section which goes in these three dash
blocks we could call these front matter
we'll talk more about front matter
inside of markdown files but inside of
these three dash blocks we can add any
sort of JavaScript that we want
including importing other components so
you can see we import our layout and our
card and in this case we can find both
of these in their appropriate
directories under layout is the first
one if we scroll down we see a reference
to slot now slot is where we're going to
take whatever information is in between
this component when we use it the layout
component and then inject that right
inside of the component that we have
defined here so what this looks like if
we come down to our index.astro since we
wrap this entire page which has a lot of
code in it since we wrap this entire
page with this layout component all of
the stuff in between
the layout tags which is here all of
that is considered the slot and that
will be rendered inside of this layout
component right here so inside of the
body now inside of the layout you'll
also see a few other things you'll see
that we can Define typescript interfaces
for our props after we Define those we
can then de-structure those properties
and then use them inside of our
application
just like we're using the title inside
of the title tag inside of the head for
our application now notice we can use
these JavaScript variables by putting
them in between the two brackets so
inside of these two brackets we're able
to basically kind of write JavaScript
here which enables us to use variables
that we defined up above
so in this layout file you'll also see
the other components that make up a
basic HTML file you'll see the doctype
defined at the top you'll see the HTML
tag you'll see head and we'll we'll see
a few different of our meta tags here
like description viewport Etc we'll also
see a reference to our title and then if
we scroll down we'll see a lot of CSS in
here now Astro has a few different ways
that you can write CSS one of the ways
that you can do that is just by adding a
style tag right inside of your Astro
components now this may or may not make
you excited this is something that gets
debated about whether or not your style
should be co-located with your actual
markdown and with your JavaScript but in
Astro you have the ability to write all
three together so your JavaScript your
markup or your HTML and then your Styles
in here as well
now style is typically in here are
scoped to a given component
so you can see here that we have an is
global tag that's associated with this
style which means all of these styles
are going to be applied to every single
page on our application versus if we go
to our index.astro component and scroll
down there's going to be Styles here and
these styles are not Global they're only
referencing material that's inside of
the component that it's in which in this
case is a page component which is the
index.astro now we can see another good
example of this with the actual card
component you can see we Define our
props here we destructure those props we
have markup we reference those
properties inside of our markup and then
we also have style tags down here as
well now again these styles are only
applying to things that are inside of
this card component and won't be applied
anywhere else so an example of this is
if I were to select the main tag and did
a background color of red this actually
won't appear to have any difference or
make any difference on our application
and that's because there's no main tag
inside of this card component and these
styles are only applied to that however
if I went to the layout and I now chose
to select the main tag and did a
background
of red now we'll see that this red color
is going to come into play because these
styles are Global and are going to be
applied anywhere there is a main tag so
really important to remember that the
Styles inside of Astro by default are
scoped to that component and won't be
interfering with other styles that you
have in other components
now in this case in this crash course
we're going to use Tailwind CSS to style
our application so we're actually not
going to worry about all these styles
that are defined inside of here we'll
come back and clean these out in a
minute and kind of reset this with some
beginner styles for us to work with but
if you were building an Azure project
yourself you do have a few different
ways that you could choose to do CSS in
this case we are just going to use
Tailwind CSS which has become incredibly
popular
so that's the majority of the basics of
the layout for your code inside of the
source directory there's a few other
files a git ignore file which is pretty
standard there's also the astro.config
file and this is really important
because this is where we can add
Integrations in Astro we can also Define
different things about our project like
how this project is going to be built
and where it's going to be hosted so by
default Astro is a statically generated
site we'll talk more and more about this
we don't have to configure anything for
that to be supported but if we wanted to
convert this to be a server-side
rendered site we could configure this in
here and then configure where and how we
want to deploy this at the end of this
video we'll talk about deploying this to
both netlify and versel but in this case
we don't have anything to change yet in
the Azure config although we will come
back to this shortly next up we have our
package.json with a few commands on how
to run the project we have the readme
and then we have a TS config which just
extends the typescript config that comes
from Astro so is going to give us all
the basic rules for working with
typescript inside of our Astro project
you could go and customize that in any
way that you want to but in this case we
don't need to now I want to take a few
minutes to talk about setting up your vs
code instance to work with Astro in the
best way now the most important thing
you'll need to install is the actual
Astro extension which comes from Astro
themselves now what this does is it
allows these Astro components these
Astro files to be recognized as Astro
files so that we get appropriate
intellisense coloring Etc so notice down
at the bottom here that vs code is
recognizing this as an astrophile and
then based on that and based on this
extension knows what to do and how to
color this now if we were to disable
this just to show you what this looks
like and we restart this all of our code
highlighting our syntax our intellisense
Etc goes away inside of these Astro
components and vs code considers this to
be a plain text file which is obviously
not what we on so you'll want to make
sure to install the Astro extension to
get all of the benefits that come along
with it it's by far the best way to work
with Astro so I'm going to enable that
and notice all of that comes back now
another one that I have installed is an
astro Snippets extension there's lots
that you can do with Astro in terms of
different types of file different things
you might want to do this is a great set
of Snippets that you could start with
that kind of help generate components
quicker and easier for you as you're
going along
now there's one more extension from the
Astro team which is the Houston
extension now Houston is the actual
mascot for Astro and they've built a lot
of fun things around this so with the
Houston extension you get the Astro vs
code theme mimicking the colors from
Houston which is pretty neat I like this
a lot in addition to that inside of the
file explorer you get a little Houston
Tab and you get kind of an animated
Houston icon that shows you whether or
not your application is running well or
not based on it being happy or sad so
it's a nice little touch to kind of feel
like you're inside of the Astro
community so you can install this and
kind of have some fun with that if
you're interested now me personally I'm
using my personal James Q Quick theme so
if you're interested in having your
colors look exactly like mine you can
search James you quick to get set up
there the last thing I want to show you
is the Tailwind CSS intellisense
extension this is one that I use all the
time when working with Tailwind so that
it helps me kind of auto complete or
remember what all the different styles
are that that I'm trying to work with so
you'll see this more as we work work
through this and start writing some code
now with all of that set up let's go
back to the Azure documentation and see
how to install Tailwind so let's just
search in the documentation for tailwind
and we'll be taken to the Astro JS
Tailwind extension or integration that
we can add
which is one of the really cool things
about Astro is that it comes with
Integrations which makes it really easy
to add support for other UI Frameworks
for example to be able to deploy SSR to
different places and a bunch of other
really neat things so let's scroll down
we can kind of skip the why tailwind and
let's come down to the npx Astro ad
Tailwind command which allows us to add
Tailwind in one command and be able to
work with it right after that so let's
stop our running application let's paste
in our MPX Astro ad Tailwind command and
this will kind of walk us through what
it's going to do to make sure we're okay
with it doing all of these things so do
we want to allow it to install the
Tailwind CSS extension and the astrojs
Tailwind package yes absolutely in this
case it says it's going to generate a
tail 1 config file which we absolutely
want so we'll say yes and then lastly it
says it's going to update the Astro
config file to be able to support
Tailwind so we'll say yes to that as
well now just to confirm what this did
let's search for the Astro config file
let's open this up and what it did is it
added an integration section here and
then inside of that array it added a
call to the Tailwind function that gets
imported from the astrojs Tailwind
package so this in theory is how we
would manually install Integrations into
our applications but in this case Astro
gives us this command the Astro add
command to be able to do all this stuff
for us which is really really nice
so let's go into our layout file and
let's get rid of all of the styles that
are defined in here because we're going
to use Tailwind for our Styles and not
use the built-in styles that come with
the application now just to make sure
let's go ahead and run this to have this
running we can make a few changes inside
of this layout file to start to get the
base of our application going
now the first thing to notice is that
we're only defining one property that
could be passed in as props which is the
title now we could additionally add
extra ones like the description we can
have this be optional so we'll have that
be defined as a string so the optional
question mark or the question mark
denotes this as optional and we can also
Define an image in here as well so now
that we get all three of those we can
destructure them so that we can be able
to use these as well
all right so we have these three
properties but we're not using all of
them just yet we're only referencing the
title and not the description or the
image yet so inside of the content for
the description we could reset this
to be description
and we can also reference our image by
using it for the OG image type now we're
not going to get all the way into all
the different OG tags that we could use
let's start with a meta tag with a
property
of OG
image and then we'll say the content is
going to be that image property that we
pass in so we'll put this in here as
image
now one thing you might be wondering is
what if the description and the image
are not passed in here we should
probably have a default property that we
can use so in this case for the
description we can set the default right
in line in here by doing equals and then
assigning this to a string now what
we're building is a an application
called Rhythm Nation and this is a
community
of music producers and in
enthusiasts and then we want to give a
default value to the image as well now
we'll come back to this in the images
section but I'm going to set this to a
default
of Slash Images slash band dot jpeg now
remember we talked about the public
directory what this is referring to
would be a file ban.jpg inside of an
images directory inside of public but
we'll come back to that in a little bit
for now we're just kind of setting these
by default now just to show that these
are coming up we can come
back to our running application which
now looks a little bit different because
we got rid of those Styles and if we
look inside of the head we should see
that we now see our description here we
also see our OG image which if we try to
access will not be available yet then we
still have our same title which is great
so all those things are working well
there's a lot more that you could dive
into with OG tags for helping your
website show up on social media
post for example or embeds and slack or
Discord but that's a conversation for
another day just know that you have
complete control to add all of those
inside of here
now inside of the layout what I want to
do is add some Tailwind classes in here
and what we can start with is a Min
height of screen
so before we save that let's go and look
at the body tag in here and if we see
this body tag is not taking up the
entire height so we can start to style
that a little bit with Min h of screen
and now we should see that this body is
now taking up the entire height which
also is confirming that our tail one
classes are working
now from here I want to add a header
component that can show the basics of
our application so in this case I'm
going to copy a little bit of code but
inside of components I'm going to create
the header.astro component and I'm going
to paste in some starter code for us to
work with now we'll walk through the
code that's here so we Define our header
we give some Tailwind CSS classes again
this is not a crash course on Tailwind
specifically but we have some classes
for our header we then have an image
icon that we can have to show in the top
left we'll come back to that in a second
then we have a few links to the
different pages on this application like
the home page the about and the blog
so from here what I want to do is import
this into our body or into the body of
the layout component so I can actually
Open Bracket and start to type our
header and then oftentimes I'll get
intellisense for this but it looks like
it's not opening for me so I can go and
do a manual import up here instead so at
the top of this we can import header
from and then we'll go back a directory
into the components directory and then
grab the header.astro
so we could save this and we should now
see the basics of our application
starting to come together we have our
header up here we have a missing icon up
here and we'll need to add that inside
of our source code so that we can
actually have this show up so one of the
things that we can do is go ahead and go
to the Astro course demo final source
code and then inside of the public
directory we have an images directory
and we have a heartbeat.png both of
which we're going to need so we can
click on the heartbeat.png and we can
download this so we can download that
file and then additionally we're going
to need the images directory as well so
from the images directory we can
download this directory as well
all right so that should download all of
those files
and so what you'll need to do is go and
find the heartbeat image and then that
directory that we just downloaded and it
will add that into our source code so in
this case I'm going to take the
heartbeat.png and I'm going to add this
into the public directory so there that
is there and if we look inside of our
header it's referencing slash
heartbeat.png which should reference a
heartbeat image right inside of that
public directory so now if we come back
and go to our application
and refresh we should see that heartbeat
icon is starting to show up which is
great now the other thing we wanted to
do is take those images that we
downloaded in the zip folder and add
those to the public directory as well
so inside of the public directory I'm
going to create an images
folder and I'm going to drag all those
images that we just downloaded into that
folder so into the images directory here
now one additional benefit of that if we
remember is back in the layout component
we defined a default image
for our OG image to be inside of the
images directory just like we did and
then the band.jpg so this now should be
the default image that shows up for our
OG image tags and actually we can test
this by going directly to this inside of
the URL so we go to slash images and
then slash band dot uh not jog but JPEG
and we should now see this entire image
showing up so we know that that is
working as well so we have our images
copied over which is exactly what we
want we have our header showing up up
here above we have links to our
different pages which we haven't created
yet and now we can go into our index
component that root page
and we can get rid of all of the Styles
so we can delete all of these Styles and
we can delete all of the main content
that's in here as well so let's just
scroll all the way through and get rid
of everything inside of Main
and in this case we're going to update
this title to be relevant to the blog
post the blog site that we're working on
which is the Rhythm Nation blog so it's
just the demo idea here but
let's go ahead and type that in Rhythm
Nation blog and now we can add a title
to this as well so I'm going to actually
create a new component for an H1 that we
can reuse so we'll create an H1
component dot Astro I'm going to copy
over the tiny bit of code that we have
for this where we Define our props we
take a text property as our prop we
destructure that and then we put it
inside of an H1 that already has the
Tailwind Styles created so I'm going to
save this and then back inside of the
index
we can now reference our H1 component
and we'll pass in a property
of rhythm
nation and then we'll need to import
this component so that we can reference
it so we'll import H1 from and then
we'll go into that components directory
and then we'll grab the H1 dot Astro and
now we should see a basic title showing
up now one thing you might notice is
that we need some spacing on the outside
of this so one more component that we're
going to create is the main dot Astro
component and what we're going to do is
use this component to wrap all of the
other things that we do so in this case
I'm going to open up a main tag
and then we'll pass in everything in
between as the slot and then we'll just
add some Tailwind classes in here so
we'll have a px of 24 which is padding X
we'll set a Max width of 7 XL we'll set
MX to be Auto which is going to
automatically Center everything
horizontally and then we'll set the
width to be full and then lastly we can
set the padding to be 5 on screens
that are at Max small size so this is
saying that we'll have a padding X of 5
on screens extra small and small and
then above that anything bigger will
have a padding X of 24. now the last
thing we'll need to do we can actually
duplicate this import we can import the
main component
from that components directory and we
can now use our main component instead
of just the main tag and that should
wrap everything and give some spacing on
the outside so now we have a clean
section here for our main content that
has that padding on the outside we have
our header we have our images loaded and
we can start to do more with this
application by building out blog
functionality and leveraging the content
collection feature in Astro which is one
of my favorite features of Astro now if
we look at the final demo from the full
Astro course we can see we have a home
page where we show a bunch of blog posts
we have tags Etc but what I want to show
you is that if we go to the slash Blog
Page we can see a list of all these blog
posts which is what we're going to start
to work on now so we can see a list of
all the blog posts in addition to
all the images that are associated with
them so if we scroll through we can see
these blog posts and then if we click on
one we'll actually be taken to the
specific route for the individual page
so notice inside of the URL we have our
root URL slash blog and then slash the
title of that blog post and a sluggified
version which means having dashes in
between all of the words so let's start
to work on setting up our application in
this crash course to be able to work
with markdown using content collections
in Astro
so let's go over to the Astro
documentation and let's search for
Content collections so what content
collections are are a way to organize
and manage and author content in any
Astro project and in my personal opinion
this is the best experience for working
with content specifically markdown and
or MDX content that I've ever seen
across any platform which gets me really
really excited so our content
collections again give us a way to
organize all these inside of a special
directory in Astro called content
directory so under Source slash content
we can then create a directory for each
different type of content that we want
to create in this case their demo they
have newsletter in our case we will have
blog and that's where all of our blog
posts will live as markdown files inside
of there now you can scroll down and
find a lot more about this with multiple
collections Etc but the one thing I do
want to show you is how to define
collections inside of the content config
file which is a typescript file and
allows you to Define types for your
individual collections like the blog
collection using Zod to have typescript
type associated with each of your
collections so you define a collection
you define a schema and you can Define
all the different properties that are
going to be associated with each piece
of content now before we actually get
into the code the one thing we will need
to do is go back to the Astro course
demo and we'll need to download some
sample markdown files that we have in
here to reference inside of our
application so inside of the Azure
course demo there is the source
directory and then inside of there just
like we talked about is a Content
directory and then inside of there is
the post directory so what you'll want
to do is go and download this entire
directory of all of these posts
now after you do that you'll want to
make sure to extract all of those and
then we'll go inside of our source
directory we'll now create our content
directory and then inside of there we'll
create another new folder called posts
and then we'll take all of that that we
just copied
and drag it into the post directory
now one thing I did Skip from copying
over is the images directory that you
can see here but that's something we'll
come back to when we get into image
optimizations so let's just take a real
quick look at what we have inside of
this content so inside of here we have
our front matter at the top of each one
of these markdown files and we have an
author we have categories we have a date
we have whether or not this blog post is
featured we have a cover image to be
referenced and then we have a title now
this is all the front matter what we're
going to do with content collections is
Define a data type that represents this
and stores or or gives us intellisense
inside of our Editor to know which of
these properties to associate with our
given blog posts specifically with a
given collection which in this case is
our blog post now at the bottom of this
you can see all of the sample markdown
that's included here so this is just
some getting started markdown so we have
something to render you could obviously
go and create your own markdown with
your own content if you wanted to
now one thing I do want to change is the
reference to where these images are
stored so actually I'm going to select
this whole thing and I'm going to do
command shift F on Mac or Ctrl shift F
on Windows and I'm going to change this
slightly and I'm going to get rid of
this leading dot in each one of these
blog posts or each one of these markdown
files and we'll come back to that again
when we talk about updating our images
to work with the image component that
comes with Astro to optimize our images
but right now I want this to point to
the public images directory where those
different images are again we'll come
back to this in a minute so we have our
sample markdown and now we need to go
into the content directory and we need
to create our config dot TS file so
let's start to work on defining a
Content collection inside of this config
file now to start we're going to import
the Define collection
function and then the Z for Zod
from the Astro
content
import so this is giving a little bit of
an issue saying it cannot be found this
should be okay so as we go through this
we'll make sure to run it just to make
sure and then from here I want to Define
my post collection and this is going to
call the Define collection function
we'll call this and we'll pass it a
config object now this config object
will then have a schema
and we'll say that the schema is going
to be a z dot object which is a function
and we'll pass that a configuration
object as well so we're using Z dot
object to say that this schema is going
to be an object and then now we can
Define the different properties that
it's going to have so we can Define it
to have a property of author and then
using Z which is Zod we can say where
this is going to be a string then we'll
have a date which in this case is also a
string
will have an image which is a string
we'll come back to this in a minute and
then we'll have a title which is a
string as well now the cool thing about
Zod is that it has other data types that
you can work with where you can add a
lot of customization on what exactly
these types should look like
and then lastly what we want to do is
export a variable called collections and
this is going to be an object and we'll
say a key is going to be post and then
it's going to have a value of posts
collection and it's really important
that this word here match up with the
name of the directory that that content
is in so those two things should match
which means our post collection should
be inside of this post directory inside
of content so now that we have our
definitions for our content we want to
start to query this content so that we
can start to display this inside of our
slash blog page so to do this we'll need
to create another component inside of
our Pages directory and we're going to
create the blog Dot
Astro component now in here we can start
to query our content by referencing the
get
collection function that comes from that
Astro content namespace so this is going
to be a function that we can call
to get the content associated with a
specific collection so in this case
we're going to assign this to a variable
called post we're going to await a call
to get collection and then inside of a
string we're going to pass it the name
of the content that we're looking for
now notice it gives me intellisense in
here because it knows what the different
content collections are that I've
defined so I can now query these posts
inside of here and now we can be able we
should be able to log the post to the
console
so important to note with Astro
is all of this code is going to be run
statically at build time so it won't
quite look this way when we run this now
but when this is deployed all of this
content is going to be queried and
generated at build time and then
deployed statically we'll talk more
about this as we convert to SSR later in
this video but in this case we should be
able to go back to our site
we should be able to click on the blog
page nothing will show up but if we go
back to our logs we should see that this
is actually querying all of this content
which is pretty nice
so what I want to do is start to be able
to display the basics here so one thing
I'm going to do is copy over the
structure of a page from that root page
and now we'll say this title is going to
be a Blog and then Rhythm Nation maybe
not Rhythm Nation blog because that's
repetitive we also have missing Imports
so I can do command and period and go to
add all missing Imports this would be
control period if you're on Windows
machine now we have all of our Imports
and then we can also update this to be
blog so now we should at least have the
basics of a page kind of showing here so
Rhythm Nation blog so that's great but
now we want to actually be able to
display that content so one one of the
things that we could do is we could
iterate through our posts so we could
say post Dot and then map and then get a
reference to each post and then for each
post what do we want to return
so inside inside of here we could start
with an H2 and then reference the post
Dot
data that's going to be all of our front
matter and then inside of here when we
press enter we now get intellisense for
all those properties which in this case
I'm going to choose the title so this is
not going to look great but at least we
have the ability to show that all these
post titles are being queried here
now the other thing we might want to do
is wrap this all in an anchor tag so if
we
kind of stub out an anchor tag here and
wrap our H2 what we want to do is we
want to set the href to a particular URL
that will take the user to that blog
post so in this case we can Define this
ourselves by using an ESX template
literal string and we could say this is
going to take the user to slash blog
slash and then inside of our Temple
literal string we can reference the post
dot slug so this is going to be the
sluggified version of that based on the
name of that actual file so now each one
of these should be a link to that blog
post even though that page doesn't exist
yet so if we hover on this on the bottom
left you can see it links to slash bog
slash blah blah if we click on this it
doesn't exist and that's our
responsibility to go and create that so
we want to do a couple of things in here
to make this look a little bit better
we'll cheat a little bit and copy in
some components to help us we'll start
with the post list dot Astro component
now in this case what we're going to to
do is Define
our props to take in a prop of post
which is an array of a collection entry
of the type of posts now again post is
going back to that collection that we
Define and we're just saying we have a
an array of those posts that we're
passing inside of here now then we have
our Tailwind CSS to be able to display a
CSS grid here with two columns on bigger
screens and then go down to one column
on smaller screens and then we display
each individual post with a post
component that we haven't created yet so
inside of our post our inside of
components we'll create one more
component and this is going to be the
post component that we can paste in
all right so very similar we Define a
prop in here where we're going to take
one property which is a collection entry
of posts so it's one post we then
destructure that and now we can
reference each piece of that data so
notice we also have the same kind of
Link in here with an H2 where we have
the post.data.title then we have the
link that's linking to slash blog and
then the slug we also are referencing
the body of our blog post but we're
using a few CSS or Tailwind CSS classes
or one and here to say line clamp of two
this will give it a maximum line maximum
display of two lines and then use
ellipses to finish it out
and then at the top of this we're also
referencing our image which will come
back to in a minute as we go and
optimize these in a second so we can
save this we can save the post list
component let's go back to our Blog Page
and let's get rid of this log and just
make sure all this stuff looks good so
let's scroll to the bottom of these logs
in the terminal there we go and then now
if we refresh our page here nothing
looks different because we actually need
to use that post list component so we'll
replace the anchor tag that we wrote
we'll reference the post list component
and then we'll pass into that our post
property that we queried above
and then we'll need to also import this
so I'm going to copy the layout import
paste in and post list and then paste in
or type in post list here as well
and this is from the components not the
layouts directory
so now we should see that we're actually
loading each of these posts and it's
linking to the individual page for that
post so notice this doesn't display yet
because we haven't generated those pages
but we do have the ability to link to
each individual blog post which is
pretty neat now let's go ahead and
generate the pages for each one of these
now to do this let's go to the Astro
documentation really quick to kind of
show you how we're going to so we can
search for dynamic routes and in this
case what we do is Define a file that
basically is going to have a placeholder
in the file name that tells us some
property that we can use to then query
and display the appropriate information
for that post now in our case what we're
going to reference is the slug of the
blog post so inside of our Pages
directory we can create a new folder
slash or blog and then inside of here
we're going to create a new file that
says inside of brackets Slug and then
dot Astro now what this means again is
that we're going to be able to get the
slug for each one of these posts by
defining each one of the different
routes that we have
now the way we Define each one of these
routes is we open up our JavaScript
snippet here and then we're going to
export a function called get static
paths this is going to be an async
function
and then inside of here we want to query
all of our posts so just like we did
before we'll call git collection
and we'll pass in the posts name
and we'll need to import that git
collection function so we'll import this
git collection and we'll also import
collection entry
from Astro
content
and once we have each one of our posts
what we want to use what we want to do
is use those posts to be able to
generate the path that should be created
by Astro for each one of these different
individual blog posts so we're going to
create a paths property we'll take our
post variable we'll map through it we'll
get a reference to each post
and then inside of here we want to
return an object and this is going to
have a couple of different properties
the first one is params so now inside of
our prams these are params that we can
pass directly to this component so we
want to pass in that slug property and
it's going to come from post dot slug
and then we want to pass in our props so
our props is going to be the post itself
so by the by exporting this get static
pass function we're basically defining a
path and a property for each one of
these blog posts that will generate
statically for application
now from here we can kind of Define how
this component is going to work so we'll
Define the props type this is going to
have one property of posts that's going
to be a collection entry it's also going
to be referencing that post collection
so we'll have one post is being passed
in we can then destructure this so we
can get the post from Astro dot props
and then from that post we can grab the
content so we can destructure the
content itself
from the post.render function which is
an async function
now from here we want to kind of lay out
a blog post page just like we've done a
few times before so let's copy over a
few of these different components and
let's just paste this in so I have our
layout
we'll have our main and we'll have our
H1 and we can import all of these at the
top so we can import layout
and we can import the H1
and lastly our main
and so we've imported all three of the
components that we're going to use in
here and just to start we can now start
to update a bit of information based on
this individual blog post so in this
title we want this to actually be the
title of the blog post that we're on so
we can take post dot data
dot title
and then inside of our H1 on the page we
can do the same thing so we want to
reference our post.data DOT title
so what we should have done now is we
should have generated a page for each
one of our blog posts that will in this
case just display the title of that blog
post so if we click on one of these blog
posts from the slash blog page it should
take us to this page but it looks like
we have some sort of error in how we
defined our git static path function so
it's expecting an array but got
undefined so let's go back up and double
check that
so it looks like we defined our path but
we didn't return this in the end so the
most important part about the get static
path function is it has to return those
paths so that Astro knows what to do
with them to generate the individual
pages
so hopefully that will handle this now
if we refresh we see the title now
coming up at the top and we have our
individual blog post Pages for each of
these individual blog posts so that's
great we have each of those defined we
can now kind of copy a little bit of
code from the post component so if we go
back to the post component and look at
the image we can now copy this end just
so we're starting to display some more
things on here so if we paste this in
under the H1
we should now see our images popping up
so it looks like it's not quite the size
that we want because we're now shrinking
this to be a width of 600 so we can
update this to be 1024 and I think that
should give us now kind of the full
screen or almost full screen page that
we're looking for and then lastly we can
render this content component that we
got from the render function of our
posts so up here we called post.render
we got the content component we can
render this but it's not going to look
great so you can see we have all of our
content here but this doesn't quite look
great and that's because we don't have
any Styles defined for this
now in our case what we're going to use
is the Tailwind CSS typography package
to handle this for us so Tailwind CSS
typography you can search this basically
what we're going to do is install this
plugin and then we'll be able to use
this inside of our page to be able to
display this stuff appropriately so I'm
going to copy this install command let's
go back let's paste
this in this is going to install the
Tailwind CSS typography package
then inside of our Tailwind config we
need to make sure to reference this so
we're going to inside of this array
require
and then we're going to require the
Tailwind
CSS typography package
and then lastly for this to work inside
of where we render our content we're
going to need to wrap this in a class
or a div
that has a few classes primarily the
pros and Pros 2XL class so those are the
classes that kind of activate this
extension or to be able to use that
plug-in to be able to render all of our
content
so let's go ahead and run this with our
run Dev command we can now come back to
our application we can refresh this and
we should see that this now is looking a
lot better and this is starting to feel
like a real blog so we have if we go
back we have a list of all of our blog
posts
and then we can click on the individual
Pages see the image and see all the
content which is pretty neat
now one thing that's interesting that's
not very optimized on here is the way
we're referencing our images so if we go
into our Network Tab and just look at
our images as they load in we'll notice
a couple of things a couple of things
we're loading all of these images even
before we scroll down to see them so
that's a little bit unnecessary it would
be more optimal if we were only loading
images as we're getting close to
scrolling down to them then we'll also
see that these are being loaded as JPEG
files which are not the most optimal
format webp would be a better format and
see that these are really big images so
six megabytes four megabytes Etc so we
can use the Astro image component to
make this a lot better and much more
optimal so let's go back to the Azure
documentation and let's just search for
image and let's just go to the top level
images here
and let's go down to the actual image
component which is what we're going to
use to be able to do a lot of
optimizations with our images
so we can import the image component
from the image assets namespace and
basically just replace the regular IMG
tag that we were already using we'll
have to do a few more things in here but
let's start with that so inside of our
post component we can copy in the import
for this image component and we can now
replace that IMG with our image
component now if we come back to our
application we can see that this is
going to work but nothing has really
changed so we're still loading all of
these files and they're still jpegs and
they're still pretty big so one of the
things we want to do is actually move
this image's directory into our content
directory
and actually specifically we're going to
move this into our slash post directory
because these are going to be all the
images that are associated with these
posts now then inside of our markdown
we're going to update if you remember we
changed this at the beginning we're
going to select this little bit and
we'll do command shift F or Ctrl shift F
to select all of that and what we want
to do is we want to update this to go
from slash to dot slash so slash implies
that it should look at the root of the
application which is at the end of the
URL dot slash now means we should look
relative to where the actual file is so
in this case it's going to be relative
to where this markdown file is and
that's going to be inside of that post
directory so I'm going to update each
one of these posts to reference
dot slash image
and we would think that would work but
we actually have an error in here of
something isn't working that's because
we need to go back to our config for
Content Collections and we need to
update our image property to actually
use and image object that Astro gives to
us
so what we're going to do is turn
instead of returning this object
directly we're going to turn this schema
value into a function
and so this is going to then return that
Z dot object but by defining this as an
a function we can now destructure a
property called image and now we can
reference our image type to be of Type
image or call that image function so
this is going to more explicitly
references as an image in a way that
Astro can understand in a way that could
also import those images from the
content or inside of the source content
directory so let's try this one more
time
run this again
so the first thing that you notice so
you might notice is that the URL for
these images are looking kind of weird
that's because Astro is using kind of
internal URLs to Define how to render
these images so if you look really
closely you can see it defines the
format and width and height Etc but we
can see that these are loading webp
images and that these are much smaller
than what they were originally so our
page now is going to load much faster
because these images are much more
optimized and they're a better format
and they're much much smaller now if we
click on one of these individual Pages
notice that this isn't working and
that's because we're referencing this
using the old image IMG tag which can't
be referenced here so let's go into the
slug page
and let's just update this to use the
image component from Astro assets and we
should be able to just say this as is
and have this be working so now we're
able to load this image and this should
also be choosing a webp version of this
which should be smaller than what it was
originally so now we have a working list
of all the blog posts we can then go to
the individual page for a blog post we
see an optimized image and we can see
all the content associated with that
blog post as well now with all this in
place there's one really neat thing that
we can add that's really easy in Astro
and pretty amazing if we look at
navigating between these Pages we see
kind of this page refresh we actually
don't have the about page created but we
see kind of the page refresh as we go
between individual pages and we can
actually make this a little bit easier
by using the view transitions API in
Astro this will only take a second to
add but it does make a big difference in
how you can view and navigate through
your application so inside of the view
transitions API you can you can read a
lot more about this we can basically
import this component and then use it
inside of the head of any page that we
want to have those transitions between
so since we want to by default use this
on every single page we can actually
just import this inside of our layout
file and then somewhere in the head we
can just reference this View
transitions component and save and now
we're actually going to be be able to
see a difference between how we navigate
our Pages this is pretty neat so let's
go from this page to home notice we get
kind of that animation we go to blog we
get animation we see this page we get
the animation so it looks like a much
much better experience of navigating
between pages with just one component
that we can add now there's some
additional ways that you can customize
this you can also Pass State from one
page to another which is pretty neat we
won't go any deeper into this but it is
nice to know that we can add this pretty
easily to make the transitions that our
application look look a lot better now
one additional thing I wanted to show
you is that you have the ability to not
only use markdown inside of Astro for
your content you can also add MDX and
the support for this comes with a
an integration that we can add with one
of those npx Astro ad commands so let's
go and add support for markdown by
pasting in this command this will make a
change to the Astro config and install
that package so we'll just go ahead and
say yes to all the things that it needs
to do yes all right so that should be
added
and now we can do an npm run Dev to
start this again and what we should see
if we come back to our markdown files
for example the behind the scenes is we
can now rename this file
and we could rename this to an MDX file
and now all of this should still stay
the same so if we come back to the
application so if we refresh this we see
this stays the exact same which is
exactly what we wanted but now we can
harness the power of MDX in addition to
just the markdown that we were already
using
now if we scroll back up there's a quick
section on why MDX so now we're not
going to dive deep into this but there
are lots of really cool things that you
can do like MDX only features so you can
use exported variables inside of MDX so
if you wanted to create variables at the
top you could then reference that you
can also use your front matter variables
so you could use those directly inside
of here as well and the last thing is
you can reference Astro components and
UI components of other Frameworks like
react view Etc inside of this as well so
if we look in the example in here inside
of the MDX part we're importing two
different components one Astro component
and one react component that we can then
display right in line inside of our
markdown content now this is really
useful for as an example to do like a
call out inside of your blog post if you
want to customize a call out to send
somebody to a newsletter or something
else you could Define those components
and bring those into your H to your MDX
files anytime that you want or need
so we're not going to dive any deeper
into MDX that's kind of a section on its
own but it is nice to know that you have
the ability to work with both markdown
and MDX files in your content with Astro
now we can start to work on deploying
this application so we initialize this
initially as a GitHub or a git
repository so we can now do a git status
and we can see all the things that we've
changed now in this case we can add
everything with Git add star and then we
can do a get commit Dash M to say
initial commit and all of this stuff has
been committed to this local git
repository now the next step is we we
need to connect this to a GitHub
repository that we can then use to
deploy to netlify or versal so on
github.com you can go to the top right
you can click new repository and then we
can call this FCC
Astro
crash course test
we'll have this be a public directory we
don't want to add a readme because we'll
take care of that ourselves we don't
want to add it get ignore so we can
create this very blank repository and
then what we'll do is just take the code
into our terminal that pushes from an
existing repository to our local git
repository to this GitHub repository so
you can copy this section where it adds
the origin and the remote or it adds the
remote origin and then pushes everything
locally to that remote project inside of
GitHub
all right so it looked like it pushed
all of that code up if we come back to
the GitHub repository we can come in
here and see that this has been added
and so now our next step is to go to
we'll start with netlify we can do
netlify and versal these are both free
so you'll sign up with a free account
after you do you can log in on netlify
and basically what we're going to do is
add a new site where we're going to
import from an existing project we'll
choose to deploy with GitHub and then
what we'll need to do is go and choose
that project that we just created so I
can search FCC Dash and this should be
enough to pull up that project all right
so we can now pull this in we don't need
to customize anything it should pick up
on what the build command is
automatically so we can go into go ahead
and deploy this and it should run a
build and then have the site ready for
us to use after it's done
all right so it looked like this build
has finished you can now kind of choose
the random URL that they gave you and we
should see that this is deployed our
application successfully so we can see
our Blog Page we can go and click on
individual ones as well so that is on
netlify we could also choose to deploy
this on Verso almost the exact same
process you'll sign up for a free
account you can then come and add a new
project you're going to import this from
a git repository choose from that FCC
crash course project and GitHub choose
all the defaults and then go and deploy
and then after this is finished we
should have this deployed on versel as
well
all right so it looks like this has
finished on versel we can continue to
the dashboard then we can visit this at
the random URL that it's generated for
us also now so far everything that we've
done with Astro has been statically
generated pages but we can start to look
into the SSR capabilities of Astro so
Astro actually has the ability to do a
full back end if you so decide and you
have the ability to Define what type of
output your site is going to have so by
default it is static which takes no
additional configuration for us to do
but there also is the ability to Define
it as a server rendered application by
default it says to use this one most or
all of your sites should be server
rendered you can also opt into
pre-rendering or static Pages for
individual Pages you also have the
option to do hybrid which is basically
saying it's going to pre-render by
default and then you can Define for
individual pages to opt out of
pre-rendering before we make this
transition into server-side rendering in
our code let's actually take a couple
minutes to talk about the difference
between static site generation or SSG
versus SSR which is server side
rendering and we'll talk about this
while using diagrams to kind of explain
the differences between the two
so let's start with what we've already
been using which is SSG or static site
generation and this is what Astro does
by default quick reminder if you want to
follow up on this diagram later on you
can find the link in the description
below so what happens here is when we
deploy our application we deploy this to
something like netlify or versel or
there's lots of other hosts that you
could use as well so when this thing is
deploying it actually runs a build and
during that build process what happens
is for each one of those individual
pages that we have in our Astro
application it actually generates the
HTML file at build time for each one of
those so we have one for our index.html
page we have one for our blog.html page
and then additionally we have a an HTML
page created for each one of our blog
posts and that's where we Define that
export or we exported that get static
paths function where we defined each one
of the paths that we wanted to be able
to support and then to generate the
content for
so the important part about this is SSG
at build time is going to go ahead and
create the content or the HTML Pages for
each one of these Pages at build time so
that it's ready and accessible by the
time someone comes and tries to view one
of these blog posts for example or one
of these other pages and that's an
important next step to talk about is the
actual request time so what happens well
these individual files that are
generated during the build process are
then saved to a CDN or a Content
delivery Network that are replicated all
across the world what this means is that
those files now are very fast to access
and return When a request comes in from
the browser so let's say that you go to
the browser and you type in local not
localhost but you type in the URL of the
application that you're trying to work
on and you go to the index page that's
going to make a request to the CDN it's
going to now return that index.html page
now let's say you then want to go to the
blog page while you make another request
to the CDN the CDN now is going to
return blog.html or if you're going to
one of the specific Pages for an
individual blog post it's going to
return those pages as well again because
they've already been predefined now this
starts to differ a lot when we look at
SSR or server-side rendering so I've got
almost an empty diagram here for SSR
build time so with server-side rendering
you're still going to have a build
process to go through and run all of
your code you may run tests if you have
them but basically this is going to go
through and do the build of your
application and you may have some static
Pages we'll talk about how to mix these
in a second but for the most part what
this is going to do is now kind of have
that server configured so that it can
handle those requests as it comes in so
notice there's no predefined HTML pages
that are already calculated for us that
means if we scroll down now that
something has to happen at request time
when this request comes in from the
browser so notice instead of having a
CDN we now have an application server so
requests will go from the browser to the
application server now for this
application server to respond back most
likely specifically in this case with
our blog post individual blog post Pages
it's going to need to get the
information necessary for those blog
posts from the database now in our case
we're not using a traditional database
we're using embedded markdown in our
source code but it basically works the
same way so let's say that we make a
request to slash blog slash blog dash
one for example that's the website that
we're trying to go to well this is going
to now make a request to the database
let's add a new piece of text in here
and it's going to say give me all the
information that you have about blog one
so from the database the database is
going to return back the data for blog
one to the application server the
application server is now going to turn
that back into an HTML page which will
look like if we add our corresponding
piece of text to your slash blog
slash blog-1 Dot
HTML we can move this up a little bit
for readability so basically with SSR or
server side generated Pages or
applications every request that comes in
is going to go to an application server
it is it is then going to query the
database or in whatever format it is
which might be embedded markdown that
will return the data the application
server will then take that content and
turn it into an HTML page that can be
rendered on the browser and viewed by
the user so that's a quick overview of
the difference between SSG and SSR let's
go back to our code and start to make
this work inside of Astro
so in this case we can start by going
into the Astro config and we can choose
the output property to be
server now if we try to run this we
should see that this is going to break
and that's because we're doing a couple
of things that are specifically geared
towards statically generated pages so
let's go to our running application and
refresh and we see that we now are
having an issue on the individual blog
post pages and that's because the way
that we're generating those pages is
using this get static paths function and
that doesn't exist inside of an SSR
deployed application now one thing we
could do is we could look in the
documentation and we could see how to
define this as a pre-rendered page that
means it's going to generate this page
statically so if we add this at the top
of this file and refresh this actually
will go back to working as we expect so
now we see we have that blog post we can
go back to all of them and go to another
one Etc but just for practice and kind
of experience let's go back and get rid
of the pre-render and let's see what it
would take to actually figure out how to
generate generate these Pages inside of
an SSR environment now in this case what
we're going to do is go back to our page
and we can actually get rid of this
entire get static paths function
and we can
start at the top here and most
importantly what we're going to do is
destructure a property called slug from
Astro dot params now what Astro is going
to do is because of this slug definition
up here it's going to pass this log into
the Astro dot params object to let us
reference it and use that in here to
dynamically query that post from Astro
we can also get rid of our definition
for the posts and our prop types and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to get that post from in a
weighted call to git entry by slug now
this is a function up here that comes
from Astro content it's a function that
they give us and we can say what content
collection we want to get this from
which in this case is post and then we
can pass in the slug now in this case
it's going to throw an error or show us
the typescript error because slug could
be potentially undefined so we're just
going to say this is going to be a
string so that we get our appropriate
type in here
now in this case it's throwing an error
because it's saying that we might query
for a post that also doesn't exist and
what we could do we could say if that
post doesn't exist we could do an astro
redirect so we could return an astro
re-direct to
the slash four or four four or four page
just just to show that that thing wasn't
found now we could go and customize this
and do anything that we wanted to handle
it but in this case this ought to be
enough just to get this working and now
have these dynamically generated Pages
be dynamically generated with
server-side rendering instead of
statically generated pages
so if we go back we should see that we
have all of these showing up in our blog
index page and then clicking on one
should be able to show all the details
for this blog post as well so we've now
completely flipped how we're rendering
these blog posts Pages now they're
server side rendered and what this means
just to clarify is as the request comes
into this URL it's going to send a
request to the server the server is
going to query based on that URL the
individual blog post return that back
and then use that to render the page
that shows up on the screen as opposed
to previously
we had each of these Pages generated
statically at build time for all the
blog posts that we have now the cool
thing about this is we can still go back
and configure individual pages to be
configured as static so as an example on
the home page there's no reason that
this shouldn't just be a static page
so we could still export a kant's pre
render variable that's set to true and
now we'll mark this index page as static
so if we go back here this will be a
static page versus this is server side
rendered and this individual page or all
the individual Pages for our blog post
are server side rendered as well now I
do want to show one more thing that you
can do is when you have server side
rendered enabled you can Define API
endpoints so we can search for Server
endpoints in here and basically what
that allows us to do is have a file
inside of our Pages directory that just
basically serves as an API endpoint
instead of actually returning an astro
component so if we go into our Pages
directory we could create a new folder
slash or called API and then we can just
create a test dot TS now notice this is
a TS file instead of an astro component
again because it only runs on the server
and if we look in here just copied kind
of the basic uh starter code that they
give us but we're not going to reference
any of this so we can kind of get rid of
all of this information about products
and then we can return back an object
with a message that says hello world so
this is how we Define a starter function
four API endpoints so in this case we're
also not referencing this params
parameter so what we defined is a git
endpoint where we're basically just
going to return hello world as Json so
we can save this we can then go back to
our application we can then open the URL
and go back to the root and then slash
API slash test and we should get back
that message with hello world now what's
really cool is we can Define all of our
HTTP endpoints with this as well so we
could also
export a post function if we wanted to
we could return with the same thing now
unfortunately there's not a way to be
able to test this inside of the browser
because the browser can only send git
requests so I have the postman extension
inside of vs code installed so if you
wanted to follow along you can install
the postman extension this has been kind
of my default way of doing testing apis
for a long time but now they have the
the vs code extension to go with it so
we can create a new HTTP request and we
can now send a post request to the same
general idea so
localhost4321 and this will be slash API
slash test
and we'll send that and we'll get the
same response that we just got back with
the message of hello world now inside of
handling our post requests
we could also destructure the request as
well and then we could get the body
from that request
by calling a weight request dot Json
and then we could just return this just
to show that we're actually getting it
so let's just return that body which is
going to be an object so we're
destructuring this request notice we
also don't have typescript types around
this so we could Define this a little
bit differently if we wanted to I'm just
going to copy in a new kind of function
definition here so this is going to use
in Arrow function syntax where we Define
now our posts to be an API route so we
can add the missing import for that and
now it's going to give us intellisense
for the request so if we do dot we can
see all the things that we have access
to there we also then can see things
that we might have on our params in here
as well so we can now save this and what
we should see is if we go back to our
request this is a post request but it
doesn't have a body so we can now inject
in here a raw body with Json and we
could have an object and we could have a
property of a name we could say Astro
crash
course and then what this should return
back with is that same object that we
can see down here so we have the ability
in Astro to Define any and all kind of
server capabilities that we wanted we
could handle form submissions we could
Define API endpoints for all of our
different methods which is really really
cool and really really powerful so I
think the only next step is to show how
do we actually deploy this to netlify
and versel now that we're doing server
side rendering so inside of here we have
a plug-in or an integration for both
netlify and versel so I'm going to copy
and paste this command so here's the
netlify one
and let's paste this in here for netlify
and this is going to add that package
and then it's going to make an addition
to our astro.config file to use netlify
as the host so notice it says adapter is
netlify we'll say yes
and then if we look inside of the Astro
config we should see that it's
referencing adapter and netlify here so
now what we want to do is we we will add
everything we'll do a git commit with a
message of added SSR and deploy to
netlify
and then since this is already connected
to our netlify site we can push this and
netlify ought to automatically pick this
up pick up that change let's just log
back in it should pick up that change
automatically and it should be building
a new version of that that now is going
to be our server-side rendered version
so we'll let this go through our build
and then we'll open this up to make sure
everything looks okay
now as this is building one thing to
notice it's referencing netlify
functions I actually just missed it but
inside of building you can see that it
references deploying this to netlify
functions so that's how it's actually
able to deploy this it looks like
everything is complete we should be able
to open this production deploy hopefully
everything now continues to look okay
just like it did before and we can see
the individual blog post Pages as well
now next we'll need to do this for
versel so we can copy in that same
command and then add in versel and this
is going to go through that same process
add the versel package and then it's
going to update the Astro config to
reference that versl adapter so we can
say yes to that as well so now this is
updated we can add everything again we
can commit and say hosting on versa then
we can push this now do note that this
deploy in netlify we're still connected
to netlfi so this will kick off another
build that next build will fail in
netlify but what we do want to see is
inside of our cell we should see that
this is kicking off a new build and
versaille so we can see under the
building tab that it's going through and
it's doing this
so when that finishes we should see that
we have the same deployed application
hosted now on versel using SSR
all right so it looks like it's finished
we should now be able to visit this and
we have the same experience where we can
go to blog we can see all the pages we
can go to the individual page Etc
now going back to the idea of SSR inside
of Astro one of the coolest things that
you could do in addition to API
endpoints and other things is you could
start to incorporate authentication into
your applications so you have the
ability with Astro to create
full-fledged full stack applications and
you can do authentication in here by
referencing cookies as an example so you
could track a session in a cookie for a
user and you could gate pages to prevent
users from getting to certain pages if
they're not logged in or if they don't
have certain permissions or anything
like that with authentication in that
full Astro course we actually build a
basic authentication strategy using SSR
and Astro as well as taking advantages
of taking advantage of cookies and then
having that reference users that are
saved inside of a Zeta database so
another really cool full stack
implication or example of what you can
build with Astro now if you want a full
overview of what we build in that course
you can go to Astro core Dev and it
breaks down everything that we're going
to build inside of this full application
including all the topics that are
covered the pricing Etc so if you're
interested in that you can find that at
astrocourse.dev
all in all I hope you're as excited
about Astro as a framework as I am
obviously I'm pretty excited so thanks
for checking out this crash course and I
really hope that you enjoyed it